ARIZONS  J
IF T
AUDIT IN HOPES O
PREST TOHOUSEFBI N E T
BEHAVIOR INTINUALLY
D ACTIONS,
WHH  OCCURRED.
INRONT" YOU'VE  ON THIS AND HOW
SUPPORTERS AND YOU SEE A C
PARALL TAR
>> ERIN.
THERE IS AN ANTICIPATION AND ERD
WEEKS LEADING UP TO JANUAR6t
DEA THAT, YOU KNOW, THISOING TO
G
THE ELECTION WIL OVERTURNED,
SOMETHING SIMILAR THT, Y WE'RE
APPROACHHE S.
IT'S BEEN SOMEIN R
LISTEN.
>>NTED WHEN
TRUMP LO TION.
>> I WASTED HE
LACK OF TRUTH ANTH  TOOK PLACE I
IT'SOMING OUT NOW I
BE A
THE FIRST FORENSIC AUDA
PRESIDENTIAL EIO FORENSIC.SOKNO
>> DO YONUINEL POSSIBILITY --
>> TRUMP COULD OBTAIN THE
ELECTORAARIZONA,
IF THAT HAPPS, COULD I GEORGIA?
PO.IBLY.
>> SO ERIN, YOU CAN HEAR THERE
THERE ARLE OBSESSED WITH
TH BT DOMINO TO FALL AND
THEN THE ELECTION COULD GET ERI
I KNOW, AS YOU POINT
OUT THESE UR
YOU ALSOSI
A PARALLEL STIRRING UP
ORTERSIN
BIG DEAL LIKE THE JANUARY 6th C
AUDIT.
>> SY TUNED FOR ARIZONA.
IT'S GOING TO BETESTN OUTRY, VE
INTERESTING TIME.
YOU UNRS
BECAUSE IT WILL BE, U OWMEAN,?
>> I F
HOW  PEOPL THEIRM UM TONCERNING
EVNG, .
WE'VE SEEN COME D
GO.
NEN SUPPTEMEOF THEM BELIE
INAUGUON A
MARTIAL LAW WOULD BE DREAND OTH
COME BAC 4th BUT
DIDN'T ENDORSE THE IDEAS OPENLY.
WE'RE SEEING
, INCREDIBLE TO ARR PRESIDENT O
UNITEDTALKING ABOUT, YOU
OWN HIS BIDEVERN  HE DIDN'T REA
ECMP IW OUT
THERE OPENLYS
THAT THE ARIZONA AUDIT BFIRST D
INK, A VERY,Y
>> YEAH.S SITUATION.
ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU VERY M THANKS.
>> FOR YR PORTING ON THIS TW
LOOK TOR OF  U
W QANON  A SPIRACY EOF NG THAS
TOMORROW.
MIKE, LOOK, THIS IS NDE AUDITS ?
TO UNDERSTANDALS MOVEMENT'S
QANON, THIS ISEMENT.
THEY BELIEVE THAT THERE WILL BE
A GREAT EVEN ONLY  THAT
E CORRUPTI RES GOODNESS  A F ANM
THAT WASHE GREAT OCTMENTS, MASST
MISERABLE.AKING AND BI.UL STRIN
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN NOW
DEEP STATE
TARREST HIMSEHAYO IT A
PROFF P GETTIND OF
THE BAOPLE BUT AFIT OF
TRUMBEED TO OFFICETHAT'S WHERE
HE OBVIOUSLYWARE THAQA
LIRRY OUT MORE
ACTS OF VIOLENCE AND TALKED
NTHS THE
TARMER
AT A RECENT TRUMLLY.
>> IT WAS A FALSE ELECTION>> SO
>> THEY TOOK OVER AN
THE RY TOVER. T COULD POSSIBLY
E S IN CONTROL.  THEY'RE WORKIN
TOWARDS.
>> IT
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE I
>> YES. UTELY.
>> YNOECTION S US?
IST ARY OIN INVESTIGAT THEY LLIN
THOINT?
>>
QANON HAS BEEN A SECURITREE VERY
E  Q DRO L
OCTOBER 2017 SAID THAT HILLARY U
O CRUSH THE RIOTS THAT WOULD
TA O
ARREST.TH THAT IS
ALWAYS YEARNED KIND OF
THESE PEOPLE ARE JUST WAITING  F
FOR IT TO HAPPEN THEY
BUT A RE VERGEAKE IT INTO THEIOW
AND WE STARTED SEEING IT AS
EARLY AS SUMMER  WHEN YOD TH BL
QA GENERAL REPORT TO
THAT CAME FROM. ROUNDS OF
AME
IT WAS A MLES
THIS CHILD RING OF SOME SORT.
WHH  TLY UNDERSTAND THAT SOME
WOULD BELIEVE THIS
YOU'VE SEEN CHATTEG QANOT SOMET
JU I W
YOOUE THIS IALOUT TH
>> THEHAMP,
CHTH D FAMILY'S HOAWAR
VE TUSURE OF DOGR A  OR RET O T
A  T IT'SECRET
COMMUNAT
BRINGS QANON PEOPLTOGETH EY HAV
LANGUAGE THAT KEEPS
OUT ANSO OF THE THGSAS MEANING
GE ARES  DOG
THEROW PROMI PEOPND DOGE AND  T
O E THAT A MEMBEG
ING KABUL HAS DIED
GOING TO B AS A E FLAGETRATE A .
BECAUSE IT I MOS BUTKERS
OKT THINGS
>>O AUSE IT'S NOT
SOIN WITH AND PLTOO
BEESOW APROBLEM
HI.
WHAT ADVIC YOU GIVTO,  PEOPLE
WHO HAVEY MEMBERS O THEYT  W
ANEIR FAMILYISTUO THOSMI DO?
ME KINDENT GROUP, THE OF PEOPL
ARE MESHED IMEE NOE
IF YOU FEDT OF
CONTT HIPERSON
WITHIN YOUR RIGHT TO DO  SAFE.
MIGHT BE ABLE TO GETHROUGH DK IR
THYOU'RE
FEAFT ABOUT POLIR
TRUMP BUT JUST ABO SHARED
RIS
.
LET THEM KNOW YO TT TO FINVENTNE
>>YOUR TIME.
THANI HOPE EVERY